um let's see who do i play next let's
say i'm the real magnus
i had black for my last four games
d4 knight f6
yeah hi justin fedebang yeah i remember
daniel very well yeah uh he's
uh one of the top players in south
africa
so
so yeah i played him just before the
time thing is
uh knight bd2 bishop e7 bishop e2
so we're playing the london
defense which oh it's always an annoying
opening
so here white is winning the bishop pair
but he probably has to play f3 and we
can escape fed a little bit
yeah so now after after bishop g6 if
dark squares on the king side are a bit
weak
takes takes h3 h3 seems like a mistake
because of knight h5
and checked and maybe white is
okay after king d1
but it's hard to believe it because his
dark squares are
very vulnerable
um
g3 bishop takes g3
e4 i can just cast a little short
[Music]
okay
and we should b to bishop f4 now i can
probably open the d
file and try the sacrifice and i
you can play knight takes c4 but then i
can just play dtx4
through g1 only i think white wanted to
play g3
but knight takes d4 seems very strong
after takes takes king c2
can you play the karo khan once please
okay
um yeah i'll play the karaoke next game
if i'm black again
wesley would you be in the top three in
the current tata still should you have
flip played
well i i don't really know
but uh well magnus is in bad
shape so if he tends to be in the top
two every single tournament
but with him being in bad shape it
certainly opens up the door
to many other players
but i haven't played overboard just in
in a long time
so i definitely need to to prepare
harder on my chest
if i want to do welding over the board
soon but i'll have my over-the-board
chest tournament in norway
hello wesley when will he play among us
anytime
yeah i i promise just based indiana play
over the board jeff